president trump is bluntly contradicting
cdc director dr
robert redfield in an extraordinary
public disagreement
redfield told congress that wearing a
mask may protect
more people from covid than a vaccine
will
and what that a vaccine is still months
away
a few hours later the president said
redfield was confused
and he insisted that a vaccine could be
ready for the general public
as early as next month wijajang is at
the white house
we said these were pretty remarkable
statements by the president
good morning anthony this is not the
first time president trump has been at
war with scientists but this time
he unequivocally threw his own cdc
director
under the bus the president considers a
covet-19 vaccine a crown
jewel of his response and with 46 days
left to go before the election
it's no surprise he rejects any
assessment that it could take
longer than he wants it was an
incorrect statement president trump
insisted cdc
director dr robert redfield was wrong
when he testified under oath that the
general public may not have access to a
coven 19 vaccine
until later next year i called him i
said what did you mean by that
and i think he just made a mistake
he just made a mistake i think he
misunderstood the question but redfield
did not look or
sound confused at all if you're asking
me when is it going to be generally
available to the american public
so we can begin to take advantage of
vaccine
to get back to our regular life i think
we're probably looking at third late
second quarter third quarter
2021. immediately the president offered
a much
earlier date it could be announced in
october could be announced a little bit
after
october but once we go
we're ready mr trump also disputed
redfield's testimony about the benefits
of wearing masks
face masks these face masks are the most
important powerful public health tool we
have
and they are our best defense i might
even go so far as to say
that this face mask is more guaranteed
to protect
me against covert than when i take a
covet vaccine
as far as the mask is concerned he made
a mistake after mr trump's briefing
redfield issued a statement that did not
say he misspoke about vaccines
or masks which he continued to call part
of the best defense
the president who has admitted to
intentionally downplaying the virus
which has killed almost 200 thousand
americans
was asked why people should believe him
instead of redfield
because of the great job we've done
earlier in the day
former vice president joe biden blasted
president trump's refusal
to fully embrace face covering and
science
let me be clear i trust vaccines
i trust scientists but i don't
trust donald trump at this moment
the american people can't either
yesterday's drama overshadowed the cdc
rolling out a new playbook
that outlines how to start distributing
a free vaccine 24 hours after the
government approves one
president trump also confirmed another
white house staffer tested
positive for the virus though he did not
come in contact with that person
but the president still refuses to
follow his
own administration's guidelines about
big crowds and tonight
he plans to hold another campaign event
in the battleground state of wisconsin
gail all right we should thank you very
much